you know I love Bethany we're we're good
friends but she really pushed your and
you push she's your good friends yes she
is we talk more than you and me on the
phone what oh no now you just sucked
yourself I never go visit you talk
with
Bethany all the time she text me and you
Tex back I call bu you said you have
more communication with Bethany than you
do with Len that's hurtful how do you
think that makes me cut cut cut cut and
I will explain that son that's hurtful
after the conversation yesterday no I
saw I'm the worst friend
ever text back just text back we just
miss you son Miss supportive of you you
guys are my best friends I I don't have
to answer you what is she BR you know
it's insulting because we are actually
Sonia's friends and now she's
prioritizing this other person it's like
really then your priorities are all
wrong if you don't understand I'm a
friend and you don't understand I'm a
friend and you don't understand with you
we never go this way so let's it CU I
don't want you to be upset it's not that
important know I choose my private time
with you you know that my vacation's a
private time you seen me on Instagram I
seen you years and who has seen me do
you see me going out with other girls do
you see me go to lunch or shopping do
you do you no we don't okay I'm telling
you I'm not with other people it's not
that I don't want to be with them but it
makes me feel better because they're not
understanding when I'm not with them I'm
working or like looking for a place to
live these girls are like you know jet
setting I'm bouncing from couch to couch
with family
I do this I had a very good
talk
change I had a good go to that and I
apologize I don't want you upset I'm not
upset listen you you set me off you said
something about how less important I am
and it made me feel like her feelings
are hurt if I text Sonia on a Monday I
don't hear from her for two weeks she
may eventually call back and for a lot
of the girls it's sort of like a little
bit of a slap in the face cuz we've been
rooting for sonan having her back for a
long time now can we go back to Sonia's
first question about what happened what
triggered you because I know you before
the show and I knew you during the show
and you were a different person and I
know that you were triggered by
something and you triggered Beth because
she came she came you were the most
unintelligent human being I've ever had
the pleasure to be around really she
went after me and so she could say that
she was the victim of a craziness that I
have I mean anyone that knows me I'm I'm
so normal
I've had nightmares for the last week
about her stabbing me like I'm
like and even tempered you need a
freaking time out okay I don't want to
time out I want you to zip it I was well
known before and so she was like going
to take down the social life what a n b
does anyone want a jelly bean just calm
down like you're absolutely crazy okay
I'm crazy all like a joke I wouldn't
have done anything to get off that
island and I told you that the next day
I just didn't understand what trigger
you got like what triggered you cuz
you're like completely normal every time
I see you I've never even related you to
that she's not that's what I mean so for
you she's not crazy they made her crazy
she doesn't want toit she a milk down I
think out of respect for her I think we
just dro the subject I've seen her a
thousand times since then and I never
once even heard about it right you know
I like Kelly so far I haven't watched
scary Island yet but I always try to go
into all situations with an open mind I
think Kelly at this point is quirky to
be coined this name crazy Kelly when I'm
so far from that I mean crazy hot can't
have that so when I see Kelly out she's
always very confident in control and
then she said you know I'm actually not
very confident ladies I have a secret as
insecure we think we are as women men
are more insecure just you think so oh
absolutely it's a fact is it a secret
it's a tip it's a
tip
[Music]